and I his betches but I'll do it I may
be able to help right about you
herbermann don't belong on this dog we
keep cleaning here to get better too
gross Echo Lake lumber mill has power
light if you clear the land Harbor Minh
can wire up the condensers so they send
their 12-year giving up uh I know the
money's a joke if my friends through and
owe you big mm-hmm okay let's turn back
the fog let's do this [ __ ] okay well
luckily all right with that marker oh
let me level up okay where's the running
one
well I was just like running we're on
our dead it just is really good though
hmm oh let's [ __ ] i'm doing a video
preset faster one okay well let's do
this
geez
streaming for 30 minutes early wow my
ticket suck
is this
and where's my another one oh yeah I'll
do this bad boy I don't like two
slackers do with the scope okay let's do
this out there that's not their best who
the [ __ ] is that now then I fight me so
ain't none of my business ain't ahead I
know that's I guess that's the phrase of
today I know my business that's like the
best dream i think that one with the
kermit pointing out like horrible things
of other people but saying it went to
repossess is that not that it's a knob
you just kill it and save not that
that's an option
yeah it should be close yeah I can just
shoot him in the chest and I kid John
okay we're getting close let's see if
you're getting close you get Rumble
Jesus a [ __ ] Oh balls and love waffles
okay we're here Oh what am I gonna do
[ __ ] is that
well what the [ __ ] that is trying to get
rid of it holy [ __ ] Nick where are you
the [ __ ] and I like not aim today ok
what's the quest secured lumber
the [ __ ]
I say a bets I say hey I got one [ __ ] I
know we're not alone yeah what next that
what we're doing just walking around
cleaning up for this place
chef I know they smart always mar a dive
on in here right really other billing
it's a jump in too
I got him all right I kind of wake up
with you hit they hear firing hey oh
[ __ ] why can I hit this one Oh Sarah
shoot again I got I'm gonna come down
but get it yeah [ __ ] I got that [ __ ]
okay yeah i thought we had to build the
concert okay
at balch energy
probably weird
aight the care of the Bulge mad come on
birth to drown your troubles alright
[ __ ] could you keep it down some of us
transmission I cleared the lumbermill
for you we gotta go see the captain I
want you to pay 30 years okay since
someone did the dance like you but now
the phone doesn't get him to call their
own they'll come back my friends have
already sent word the Navy bowler and
back to ties you'll see heck angry look
at rapper in the eyes there something
else every day haha them an easy I
that's kind of that's the end of a
choice as a
now I ship all your medical infinity
don't let the island catch you off guard
by my guns how can the bait shop help
you and Captain
hmm
hey chaps got everything you need Bertha
excuse me ma'am smalls we got no time
the mainland air cleared up Echo Lake
lumber mill all right
the mills safe for now Utley so we gotta
act fast we gotta get off the docks
captain if you give us some of those
Acadian fog condensers my friends are
ready to homestead the bumpers surviving
is about more than we're no good here I
was wrong about you what not you you
Bertha knows this island better than you
Avery we give folks some condensers okay
a chance to build defenses will survive
all right and thrive you I can lend a
hat you would well then they're ours are
sure to be better give them the fall
convincing well I won't stop until we
deal with the children of Adam settling
the island come Bertha you might want to
check up on Echo Lake it's out for
Harambee
Oh